really Bob Thornton is out walked into
the room welcome how are you what's up
man how's it going you know what some
talking [ __ ] muffin
you know I wish I'm allergic to wheat
and dairy so alright yeah I guess it's a
no then it's probably a good thing I
mean what are you gonna do do you know
to be allergic to stuff that now
everybody says is bad for you anyway
it's probably not the worst thing in the
world right I guess so I mean you know
it's like I'm always thinking I'd
probably weigh like 700 pounds if I if I
could eat the stuff I want to yeah I was
wondering like how you keep in check cuz
you've always been in good shape but is
it just cuz your food allergies I can't
eat anything yeah Wow
when did you find out that like
medically you couldn't eat it well when
I was growing up I I just assumed that
everybody felt like hell after they ate
this is what it feels like it's the
process so just like cutting yourself
with a razor blade so I you know I went
this holistic doctor at the suggestion
of a girlfriend of mine in LA when I
first moved out there so oh man so you
went through your whole childhood indie
or no life is just a pain this is what
eating is like it's terrible exactly
because I can't eat meat like pork or
beef or anything like that either Wow
so essentially I'm a you know when I say
I'm a vegan I only I'm not really a
vegan I'm a vegan who cheats cuz I fish
and turkey is stuff like that right so
mine is not about having a particular
affinity for cows or something I just
I'm allergic to like I said wheat dairy
shellfish I have type a B negative blood
which is the rarest type in the world
and it's things like yeah less than 1%
of the population in the whole world has
it yeah does it make you feel special I
feel like on some level it's like a man
I'm unique
I'm absolutely it does right there's no
question about it i when I say that to
people I always feel a little bit
arrogant maybe negative blood yeah
rarest type yeah like you meet a person
you like yeah they probably don't have
until you get your leg sliced off your
own traffickers and you're like gee
got time yeah I guess that's the other
thing that you have to walk around this
earth making sure that you never need a
blood transfusion
how did all this happen to you do you
know I mean is it does it does does this
type of stuff run in your family or are
you just born with allergies and weird
blood and this is this is Billy Bob
Thornton I just don't know I really
don't know
my mom had a lot of allergies so maybe
it was from her you know terrible sinus
trouble and all that kind of stuff see I
always wonder what kind of allergies are
going on or anything like that because
when I grew up my mom never wanted to
believe anything was wrong with me right
and we get upset if a doctor ever said
Oh will this need some correcting no
she'd be pissed because she was
convinced that you know her Sammy was
perfect oh well so I mean there could be
a plethora of things that are not with
me and I just never I went to Catholic
school and like I have all the I had all
these [ __ ] problems but they would
always like just pray like yeah but I
don't hold the pencil right Jesus is not
helping God makes no mistakes right all
you need was it like one of those pencil
grips think that's all I need telling me
to pray I was also reading about you and
you know I mean everything you read on
the Internet is true of course my face
literally do you have a phobia of
antique furniture Oh or is this one of
those things that like you said once in
an interview and it's taken on this
whole life that is yeah yeah I I've had
a long long career of you know doing a
lot of interviews and and saying a lot
of things to people that became a thing
right and one of the things that they
said about me the antique furniture
thing is true to a degree I don't know
if you'd call it a phobia
it's just that I'm I prefer more modern
stuff you know right like for me like a
Japanese restaurant or hotel is perfect
yeah you know cuz everything is clean
simple yeah a castle in Scotland with
like old creepy velvet drapes and stuff
that's not my bag
webs in the corner that have been there
since the 1600s right the kind of stuff
and then people say was because of
spirits no it's just because it's creepy
you know right yeah so that's really
more what that is I was also pegged as a
guy who only eats orange food and that
came I'm sure from a waiter at this
restaurant I used to go to every morning
and I would get a this drink the smoothy
that was orange and I'd order papaya and
there was something else
Oh a sweet potato fries mmm and then the
next thing you know I only need orange
food it's like well I I eat orange food
sometimes that wasn't orange that was
worth about everything you know people
find you to be fascinating and so you
end up in scenarios where a guy who's
like a cashier or a waiter at a
restaurant feels like they have an
interaction with you which to you is
just like I'm just getting getting lunch
but still it's nothing it's a day-to-day
thing but it has to be special for him
because now it's a Billy Bob Thornton
and I know something about I have an
experience with him right so I'm gonna
tell the world that he only needs orange
food absolutely you sit there and go
like what the hell am I supposed to do
that is not gonna make somebody tell his
story about me it's so weird I I don't
know I've never understood it I've I've
never cared that much about people's
personal habits you know if they don't
affect me on a daily basis right you
know what I mean so there was this one
thing on the internet one time that you
know how you're looking up you know when
was Joe DiMaggio born and the next thing
you know you find something about
yourself it's like how the hell did I
get a Joe DiMaggio it's like top 10 you
know people who you know walk and
breathe who suck or whatever and so
anyways there was this thing on there
about how short I am
mm-hmm and I was thinking how the hell
did I get on a list of short guys in the
entertainment business and so I started
looking at it and that there was I mean
are you sure I mean your height height
I mean I'm 5 11 and a half that's a
great tell me about it I went to England
one time we're in the north part of
England and a creepy little house we had
to go to and the door was like what is
this leprechaun understand what was
going on but they said no that's how
tall people used to be so yeah when they
say Peter the Great was a giant he was
probably five seven yeah right you would
have powered over but one way or the
other I I kept looking after I saw that
you know how you go down the rabbit hole
now you have to know yeah now I gotta
know so I get on here and there's this
whole chat room thing happening where
people are talking about this well I saw
him in Tombstone he was standing next to
Kurt Russell and I happen to know Kurt
Russell is this tall and here and he was
much shorter than Kurt and I'm thinking
they don't know that and so anyway
supposedly I'm like five seven or five
eight really and so I always just tell
people when I do like you know you'll
have a Q&A after some screening or
whatever you know and and I'll just say
just so you guys know I'm 5 11 and a
half and you can see that stand next to
me Dennis you know yeah I mean I will
say when you walked into the studio just
now yeah of all the things I was
thinking not one of them was like my
short not why you weren't sure just
going conversation today I met Billy Bob
throwing today guys a [ __ ] no idea
you started winning awards super early
you wanted to award for Goliath RA for
season one right right but your first
award you got first Ling blade
yeah writing the the first you know act
real award I suppose I mean you know
when you're in school you get stuff like
you know you're most likely to not kill
somebody or order yeah I was actually in
the newspaper when I was seven and a
half months old
Wow black in Arkansas because as a baby
I was really fat and you could eat
whatever you wanted exactly yeah I
didn't know any different
no wonder I cried all the time but one
way or the other I uh when I was seven
and a half months old I weighed 30
pounds that's like a WoW that's like a
first grader right he's gonna say my
four-year-old daughter weighs 29 yeah
exactly and so they had me in the
newspaper so that was sort of my first
notoriety but yeah when I won the
Academy Award for Screenplay and that
was nominated for Best Actor and then I
got nominated again for a simple plan
this movie I did and a couple of years
later for for Supporting Actor and then
and the rest of it's all you know Golden
Globes and Chicago critics New York
crazy when you get it like when you get
into Hollywood and sling blades kind of
your introduction to the Hollywood
community right and you go right to the
Academy Awards does it mess things up in
the sense that you think everything
should be Academy Awards or does it take
that pressure off of like okay well I've
been here now so now I don't need to
think about this anymore
what definitely changes things I mean
and a lot of people are under the
impression that Slingblade was sir
that's when I became known with the
broad public right you know I'd been
working out there since 1981 so I was
you know it's like playing the you know
next-door neighbor creep on Knots
Landing or whatever animator so I've
been doing stuff and I've done a couple
of TV shows a evening shade of Burt
Reynolds and this show with John Ritter
and you know various movies here and
there so I had been working for a long
time and then we made a movie called one
false move that I wrote with my writing
partner Tom Everson that was made in
about 1989 or 90 somewhere in there
which got us a name within the movie
business but not with the public gotcha
and that was a critically acclaimed
movie
then when after the academy award you
just it literally does change everything
and in and on the positive side what it
does is all of a sudden everybody wants
you right it's some sort of like
get-out-of-jail-free card
yeah and yeah it's your membership
you're accepted now you're accepted yes
and so that changes everything but
you're right about that and I think
you're the person first person who's
ever said that but it's true that all
the sudden once that happens if you
don't win one yeah you think you're a
loser right yeah that's not like that's
not what you're what you're gearing
towards anymore that's not what your aim
is that's the pace car that's where the
standard has been set exam and I think
it helped because the math right you
didn't really get broadly known to
people until like your late 30s right
like he was older I'm so that's good man
you go through the stuff cuz making
handle stuff a little boats getting
stuff in their 20s now to keep you in a
[ __ ] snap guy yeah well that's right
you could just tell I'm like this is
gonna snap Chris is talking about his
experience on guy code he was like if
guy code yeah that's it's so weird that
it does put that pressure on you to all
of a sudden you got to win awards every
time you do something and then you guys
saw the what was the movie that Chris
guest did about oh the little movie and
Andrea got iteration your consideration
the movie was think it was like home for
for Purim right like that's what they
were made yeah yeah exactly and and so
somehow somebody which does happen you
know through because it's like this
weird little movie or whatever and then
somebody says something about it's like
oh this must be important next thing you
know here are these poor people these
actors who didn't expect anything and
next thing you know they're actually in
the race right and it shows like
Catherine O'Hara I'd like at her house
waiting for the nominations to be on TV
that's the weirdest thing on earth it's
like four o'clock five o'clock in the
morning
yeah and so yeah I guess so we're here
for you guys you on New York you know
it's like at a normal time in LA you
people wake up at literally 4:30 in the
morning yeah and you watch TV to see if
you're not but and then when you're not
it's the strangest feeling in the world
if everybody's already told you you're
going to be right I mean you don't
expect it who cares right so over the
years I've learned to really not think
about it yeah and so I don't even know
like I told my publicist I say don't
remind me
you know that this stuff's coming up
right now so you won't even know he's
the Eisley nominations day after the
whole thing and then if I get a phone
call at like 6:30 I'm like what happened
to somebody it's like hey
congratulations yeah okay yeah cool what
do you think is the most underrated
thing that you've done I feel like
you've done like so much and you did so
much good stuff
mmm well you know I did a movie with the
Coen brothers called a man who wasn't
there it was in black and white uh-huh
and Jim Gandolfini was in it and and
Fran and you know it was it I loved that
movie and it was largely ignored in the
States and I won the British Film
Critics Circle Best Actor Award for it
and it was what's black and white I
guess maybe a little more European kind
of vibe maybe or something but I I think
that's a I think they made a masterpiece
with that movie and it was one of their
movies that that got more ignored here
and I think I think the movie got
nominated for a few things I might have
gotten nominated for the Golden Globe or
something like that or it appealed you
see all about it here but they didn't
know about it yes here yeah and not
Roger Deakins who's their DP he's
wonderful he I think he was nominated
for the Academy Award cuz it looked
amazing and I would have to say that's
one that that was very very underwrite
to that and of course chopper chicks and
zombietown from 1987 of course that's in
my
have you had a campaign for like during
award season ever have you ever fallen
into that well you know in the beginning
you don't know any better of course I
mean they tell you that's what you're
supposed to do but you ask you otherwise
well you kind of do and that's that's
the fact of the matter is if if you just
completely stay home and you know watch
sports yeah it'd get nominated you know
usually I mean it does happen
occasionally I think these days less and
less I think probably publicity and
campaigning is more important now than
it ever was the thing is is that the
avenues in which to do it have changed I
mean with the internet see when I was
coming up there was no internet right
right so you really these days you
really got to stay active like with
social media and stuff like that you
know to kind of get out there so it's a
lot more of it although when I was you
know coming up and I remember like
Miramax did did Slingblade and I I
remember going to all these you know
trotting out to all these parties and
stuff like that it's and honestly that's
more exhausting than working that's the
most exhausting part of it right just
try and get people to the awareness
creating the awareness of you and the
project and especially now with social
media now it's like it the work never
stops entertainment it's like you you do
the movie or you do whatever then it's
like you have to promote it it's like at
least I feel like before social media
you could get a little bit of a break
you know right if you're not doing an
interview yeah or you're not at a party
I'm not promoting that's right right
like the algorithms on Instagram it's
like if you don't post every day or
whatever they're out then the Instagram
starts to push your profile down and
down and down like it was either wants
to be fed right like a monster and you
have to be aware of it you have to know
what's going on it's like nuts another
thing is and I only learned this in the
last few years is that it doesn't
necessarily mean mean anything if it's
positive or negative like in other words
if I have a hundred and thirty seven
followers or something or if I got 137
hits on something saying I'm amazing
that's not as good as having four
million hits saying I suck
oh that just astounds me right you're
like oh my god they hate me no this is
good really good
you don't understand four million people
hate you oppressions and oppressions
that bagel boss guy you know like the
star he's a [ __ ] story literally and
I'm trying to sell our comedy clubs here
I'm doing [ __ ] bananas I'm off the
side of the highway New Jersey you see
Chris I was doing the first he's doing
stand-up Kristen big yeah I got real
talent over here it's like you know when
that like that band Nickelback there
that they say Nickelback the most hated
band in the world I listen to Nickelback
and I listen to another 30 bands that
sound kind of like Nickelback why does
everybody hate them but it doesn't seem
to stop them selling records you know
and people still go to the shows
if creed went on tour I mean Creed was
like the most popular band in the world
to hate and they went on to I would sell
out every time you know Creed was the
band I hosted started out live one time
and I was offered a couple other times
but I couldn't know because it made me
too nervous yeah you know I mean that's
a hard thing to do
live on TV to be funny you have to be
funny yeah every second yes amazing and
so I did this Thanksgiving episode of
2001 and it was it was so weird because
I always thought you picked the musical
guest yourself like I would say huh I'd
see a guy who's hosting like I don't
know say Tom Hanks is hosting and Paul
Simon is the guy I bet he's friends with
Paul Simon right calls him up you know
and I kept saying you know when do I
pick the musical guest oh no no the
musical guest is already already on I
know who is it they said Creed and so I
actually introduced Creed twice um sorry
about life that's incredible I also read
do you like green and I loved in 2001
you were still there was still enough
show business naivete in you we were
like well I'm picking the band right
absolutely I was like no I told you I
was gonna get you know I was gonna get
you know Paul McCartney all three of
them Oh John the Rolling Stone was at
Paul McCartney
so go I'd season three comes out October
fourth on Amazon Prime and you've done
this thing on Goliath you also did it in
Fargo which I mean I Fargo as Goliath is
amazing Fargo is your seasons one of the
best seasons of television that I've
ever seen it's so great you have this
look that you have the ability to do
where it's like we could fight right now
and you'll be dead but I won't have a
scratch on me like it's this it's this
unnerving deathly confident you know
thing where it's like oh my god he's
serious where did you learn to look like
that I know that look he's looking at
you like I will [ __ ] kill you there's
nothing you do to kill me unless you
give me a gluten cookie and only eat
orange and is only five six you know
like where do you learn to give that
look where it's no matter what happens
here you're dead wrong and I'm walking
out well a couple of things first of all
140 pound Hillbillies are very angry but
my dad who was a he was a boxer in the
Navy he was like a hot-headed little
Irish basketball coach high school
basketball coach and he I had to fight a
lot when I was a kid and and my dad
taught me he said all you gotta do in a
fight is act like you're crazier than
the other guy he said if the other guy
thinks you're gonna kill him then you
win and of course that doesn't apply
like if you go into some you know bar
there's a guy's six seven and waistband
Alan's place for
giant he's gonna kill you yeah yeah but
but at least when you're up against
another regular guy you know it helps to
still look up in the eye side listen you
may have [ __ ] up here yeah I learned
it a long time ago yeah were you able to
avoid fights from the luck not always
now sometimes it just pissed him off
right yeah I men did they then were you
able to to follow up on that look or did
they realize okay he just learned how to
do a good look no I followed up on a few
times these days you know you don't see
fights anymore than now I really don't I
mean you see them in sports but I think
you know just regular guy fights that
you used to see in the street you don't
see it so much because people now they
carry it too far yes and then and
there's also like lawsuits and all kind
of stuff yeah I'm like well you still
you know when I was 19 you're gonna
fight with a guy you punch a guy he
doesn't call the cops on you no right no
if anything you'd settle what you had
okay and it's very different now and I
have this there's something about sports
because I'm a sports guy I watch you
know especially baseball and sometimes
when you watch these baseball fights
they don't they don't land a lot of
punches you don't notice that maybe
they're trying to compete with hockey or
something oh yeah right like they're
just sitting there going you know it'll
spice up this game right now you know
get interest every since baseball's
boring let's let's give em a show it's
also it's nobody does get punched in the
face anymore you're right like and
people need to start getting punched in
the face like I don't know why violence
has been removed from our society it's
like I I on Twitter now right you'll see
somebody tweet out something
controversial maybe like I stand by and
I'm like you're only standing by it
because nobody's punching you in the
face right okay stand by this opinion if
it meant getting punched be honest I
grew up in Brooklyn in the 90s I've had
wild opinions too and then I've shouted
them out from the bar and some buddies
come over watch me in the face my hands
hit the pavement I've regained
consciousness I've gotten up and I've
had different better opinions
[Laughter]
one more gemandsam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM avid